thanks for joining me today for ground
lesson 14 on the free pilot training
channel
in this episode we're going to be
discussing ground effect and wing tip
vortices
this is information you'll want to know
for both your check ride and your
written exam
we'll start this lesson by talking about
wingtip vortices which are a byproduct
of lift
which we discussed in a little bit more
detail in lesson two
now we discussed how the wing makes a
low pressure area on top of the wing and
a high pressure area on the bottom
but what we didn't talk about is that it
can also create lateral flow
this just means that that high pressure
air underneath the wing
rushes out then up to meet that low
pressure area on the upper surface of
the wing
when this happens downwash from the top
of the wing catches those updrafts and
pushes them back down
causing the air to spiral around the
wing tips
these are called wingtip vortices and
they're what causes induced drag
the bigger your wingtip vortices are the
more induced drag you'll have
and the size and the strength of these
vortices completely depend on the angle
of attack
so if you have a higher angle of attack
you'll have bigger and stronger vortices
which means
more induced drag now if you watch
lesson one you're probably thinking
hey i thought induced drag was related
to our airspeed
yes it is when we're at lower air speeds
we need a higher angle of attack so that
the lift
equals the weight in our airplane then
if we increase our airspeed we don't
need a steep of an angle of attack to
maintain level flight
so this gives us less induced drag next
let's talk about one of the hazards of
wingtip vortices
which is wake turbulence now i'm sure
you probably could have guessed that you
don't want to fly through another
airplane's wingtip vortices
but you especially don't want to get
caught in this behind a larger heavy
aircraft
takeoffs and landings can be
particularly dangerous if you run into
this wake turbulence
flying through these spiraling vortices
can cause you to flip over
or lose control of your airplane if your
airplane gets flipped over that low to
the ground you may not be able to
recover
so let's look at a few things we need to
know in order to avoid wake turbulence
first of all the most dangerous
airplanes you can encounter are ones
that are heavy
clean and slow heavy airplanes need to
maintain a higher angle of attack in
order to produce enough lift for flight
and we already mentioned how that higher
angle of attack causes bigger and
stronger vortices
both clean and slow airplanes must also
have a higher angle of attack
to produce enough lift to fly so angle
of attack is the big culprit here
so how do we avoid the wake turbulence
from these crazy death machines
the first way is to avoid flying through
another aircraft's flight path
these vortices sink at a rate of several
hundred feet per minute so
if you can fly above that airplane's
flight path you'll stay out of that
turbulence
the faa says you should avoid following
another aircraft at an altitude within a
thousand feet
personally i think that's a little bit
close and if i stay above their flight
path i'll stay out of their wake
turbulence
now let's see how we can avoid wake
turbulence on takeoff and landing
an airplane begins to make wake
turbulence after it rotates
then upon landing once the wings no
longer create lift the wake
ends so the best way for us to avoid
that airplane's wake on takeoff is to
leave the ground
before we get to that airplane's rotate
point
then when we land we want to land beyond
where that airplane touched down
well what if i'm not sure where the
airplane in front of me took off or
landed
a good rule of thumb is to wait three
minutes for the vortices to dissipate
that'll give you a good margin of safety
on the ground when there's little to no
wind these vortices dissipate by moving
away from each other laterally
this movement is somewhere between two
and three knots
something you really want to be aware of
is that a one to five knot crosswind
could cause that upwind vortices to stay
on the runway for an extended period of
time
in this situation i would wait the full
three minutes just like we talked about
then just be prepared to go around if
you need to do so
now that we've talked about wingtip
vortices we can expand on that and talk
about ground effect
because ground effect is caused in part
by our wing vortices being disturbed by
the ground
when you first start practicing landings
you're going to notice the airplane does
not want to land it just wants to float
down the runway
that's because your airplane is subject
to ground effect once the height above
the ground is about the wingspan of your
airplane
let's look at a couple reasons for that
now we just talked about some of the
airflow patterns around our airplane
and how these wingtip vortices are
produced but when we get in close
proximity to the ground or water some of
these airflow patterns get disrupted
for example one thing that it does is it
reduces the size of our wingtip vortices
and with that we get less induced drag
and more lift
and we already kind of talked about why
another thing that happens is you get
reduced
down wash this just means less induced
drag
with all these reductions in drag that
means less thrust is required
because of that and because we have
increased lift if you're above the
recommended landing speed
you could get considerable floating
which may not be an issue
if you're learning to land on a really
long runway
but you can see how it would be an issue
if you wanted to land somewhere where
there was a short runway
it makes sense why we want to consider
ground effect during landing
but we also want to think about it on
takeoff too
first is that if you don't use proper
techniques you could become airborne
before the recommended takeoff speed
if you do then you also leave ground
effect a couple things can happen
first of all you immediately need a
higher angle of attack to maintain your
lift
second it will increase your induced
drag which will lower your air speed
it will also reduce your stability which
means it can be tough to control your
airplane
and lastly it can make you think you're
flying faster than you are because of
the pressure
change that being said there is one time
where we want to become
airborne before the recommended takeoff
speed and that's during a soft-filled
takeoff
but the important thing to note here is
that we never leave ground effect until
reaching a good climb out speed
let's look at a couple more things to
keep in mind about ground effect
first is that ground effect affects low
wing airplanes more than it affects high
wing airplanes
and that's just because the closer the
wings are to the ground the more
susceptible they are to ground effect
there's one thing you want to remember
from today's lesson remember that ground
effect is caused by interference of the
air flow patterns
around the wing from the ground or water
i hope you got something out of today's
lesson if you did please smash that like
button for me
don't forget to subscribe and hit the
bell notification so you don't miss out
on more
free pilot training